[Musik]
das legendäre saragossa festival auf
sansibar menschen tanzen ausgelassen
touristen und einheimische gemeinsam
bands heizen dem publikum ein
[Musik]
es ist februar 2021 mitten in der
globalen pandemie cupid 19 scheint hier
für viele weit weg zu sein
ein jetlag und ihre freundinnen kommen
aus russland sie ist schon zum zweiten
mal in nur zwei monaten auf der insel
wir mögen sansibar weil es hier kein
koma virus gibt
ich war hier vor drei wochen schon mal
mit meinen kindern
ich habe drei es ist einfach nur ein
sehr sehr schönes paradies wir sind
corona frei es gibt kein corona mehr
cupid was ist das ich erinnere mich
nicht ich habe keine angst vor gar
nichts sansibar
das ist sommer sonne strand und meer ein
stadt corona maßnahmen und blockt ab wir
treffen angela aller klagt an einem der
traumstrände der insel wieder in
russland arbeitet sie als schönheits
chirurgen auf sansibar liebt sie das
kitesurfen das feiern die entspannung so
wie tausende andere besucher derzeit
auch angst vor ansteckung mit dem virus
hat sie nicht
nein weil hier alles offen ist die
menschen leben draußen das einkaufen
findet draußen statt es gibt keine
geschlossenen märkte restaurants sind
draußen auch die hotels statt auf harte
maßnahmen setzt sein silber auf
tourismus wirbt mit normalität
regelmäßig landen charterflüge vor allem
aus russland und osteuropa auf der insel
sansibar gehört zu tansania hat dort hat
der staatspräsident monatelang corona
geleugnet konkret bedeutet das seit
anfang mai 2020 gibt es keine ko-
bezahlen bei nicht getestet wird
und überhaupt alles sei unter kontrolle
sagt uns der kommissarische
gesundheitsminister der insel noch vor
wenigen tagen bis jetzt läuft alles sehr
gut
die menschen kommen und halten sich an
die vorgaben es gab keine fälle die die
regierung hätte besonders ernst nehmen
müssen wir treffen den journalisten
teile puzzle
er wurde mit einem mehrmonatigen
berufsverbot belegt nur weil er über
corona berichtet hat das thema seit
monaten tabu aber sie ist überzeugt dass
sich das virus auch auf der insel
ausbreite
wir sehen dass viele menschen sterben
es wird gesagt dass viele sterben weil
sie nicht atmen
das ist neu für uns dass jemand nicht
richtig atmen kann oder eine starke
erkältung hat aber wenn man sich das
anschaut dann sieht man dass wir hier
die gleichen symptome wie bei coop 19
die leser cookie data lipsi fordert
striktere maßnahmen um die menschen auf
sansibar zu schützen
die regierung aber bilden für die insel
so wichtigen tourismus um jeden preis am
laufen tausende einheimische sind auf
die urlauber angewiesen sowie tour guide
kassen haben du mohammed der froh ist
dass er heute eine bulgarische
besuchergruppe begleiten kann
seit fünf jahren arbeitet er in der
branche hat sich selbst deutsch
beigebracht für die vielen deutschen
touristen die vor der pandemie nach san
de bakker monatelang gab es kaum jobs
dann aber wat sansibar aktiv um
touristen
mittlerweile haben kassim zu
russischsprachige kollegen alle hände
voll zu tun
der 30-jährige verdient jetzt wenigstens
wieder etwas geld angst dass die
besucher corona auf die insel bringen
hat er nicht er muss arbeiten um seine
familie zu ernähren
ich glaube hunger ist noch schlimmer als
wenn keine touristen kommen dann
verhungern die menschen dass es noch
schlimmer
wir besuchen casino mit zuhause im
inselinneren
früher hat er bis zu 1000 euro als
tourguide pro monat verdient heute sind
es nur noch 200
er hat in ein motorrad investiert um als
motorrad taxifahrer etwas geld zu
verdienen
nebenbei baut er bananen an tut alles um
seine familie gut zu versorgen auch in
corona zeiten
ob es cupid 19 fälle in seinem dorf gibt
weiß er nicht genau
also vieles viele menschen sind aufs mal
bisschen krank und das hier ist
mittlerweile also starker mann hat doch
auch das ist etwas das man beim essen
hat man überhaupt kein test und riecht
man auch nichts ja aber geht man nicht
zum krankenhaus sondern nimmt man die
die blätter von den bäumen geholt
gekocht und getrunken und 23 tage gibt
weder nur mal kassem mohammed profitiert
von menschen wie sabine emmerich von der
größten tourismusagentur auf sansibar
sie bringt viele touristen ins land und
damit jobs für tour guides wika sie bei
ihren eigenen mitarbeitern versucht sie
das bewusstsein für die korona gefahren
zu schaffen in ihren fahrzeugen gilt
masken pflicht auch für touristen
grundsätzlich hält sie urlaubsreisen für
möglich mit den richtigen
schutzmaßnahmen
es geht darum verantwortungsvoll zu
reisen und nach einem jahr der pandemie
sollte jeder auf der ganzen welt darüber
wissen was die pandemie ist wie sie
übertragen wird und wie man sich
schützen kann
vor einigen tagen starb der
vizepräsident der insel an coop 19
vielleicht ein grund zum umdenken masken
tragen und abstand halten wird jetzt
verstärkt empfohlen an der
werbebotschaft von corona freien
urlaubsparadies rüttelt die regierung
bislang aber noch nicht